all right so Vicky you're no longer
Vicky is that right that's correct Vicky
is a nice street name what are you going
by now
Vicky is more as my street name right
when I'm when I was using him I was like
you know and then now my life being
clean sober and I'll go by Virginia
Virginia yeah that's me my birth name
your birth name is Virginia yes so I
hold that name sacred and I think that's
why I've never used it on the streets
it's just because you know so Virginia
you've gotten clean since last time we
spoke yeah which has probably been a
couple years at least yeah I'm uh
going on every four months on the 13th
this woman is sobriety on 13th from was
it Fentanyl no I was a crystal meth I
was slamming crystal meth and heroin but
then I stopped that a while back then
the last few years it's been doing crack
cocaine it's been what crack cocaine the
last couple of years oh I see yeah so
you're clean from everything everything
don't drink don't use don't smoke
marijuana and where have you been seeing
huh we're even staying I've been staying
at a sober living rbh is the recovery
Bridge housing
it's up in the valley
I don't know if you know the touchdown
Treatment Center yeah I've heard of it
yeah
that's the treatment center that I went
to I was there for a four-month program
what motivated you to try to get clean
my daughter hmm
I have a daughter too I have a daughter
yeah I was on the it's crazy how it
worked out because I remember
out working the streets
I was stressed out miserable
tired and I was just eating on me like
the drug use nothing I remember
in fact I remember that place I was
standing remember this saying a prayer
to God if I was on the corner of
essential and seventh there by the right
by that this door right down the street
the exact yeah
and I was telling that I mean God please
you know just give me a reason give me
sound to get my head on my ass and get
me on my feet because
I feel I have nothing to live for and I
have a son out there not so sad but he's
his dad and not I feel like that was my
excuse to not really fight for him
and then I was playing this give me
something and then um
three weeks didn't buy
and that just getting close to where I
should have my my cycle but someone's
telling me just go to play with each
other because I felt in my heart and my
gut you know just just got a tattoo and
I pregnancy test and to my surprise
I was pregnant
and I was
I was very excited to be honest with you
and I like I got you know but it didn't
stop there like you're thinking that oh
you're probably not even stop drugs
right
it didn't it didn't like
because of me doing a lot of work
prostituting
you can't do that sober
there's no internet sober
you had to be loaded you have to you
know
hey
so
who's the father of the child
that's the funny part I'm the dad
you know who the father is
I don't I don't know particularly that
is because you know but anywhere you can
she she looks mixed like Hispanic or
something but she's definitely not like
definitely not black but she's
definitely my child and so it matters
you showed me a photo she's very cute
thank you
she looks she says just like me when I
was a baby
like I don't know who her dad is I don't
see any other buddies in there besides
me I see me and her as I'm like I'm the
dad so where is she right now right now
she's currently in uh foster care
she does have a really great posture
posture parent she's with a couple
um they're taking one quick careburn and
uh
I'm very lucky because she lets me call
whenever whenever I want to call her I
could call him check on her and see how
she's doing
and the courts arranged so before I went
to the
um so what happened was
sometimes I was tired so
it is right now but
I lost her four days after she was born
and I had her
across the street here in Continental oh
really
that's not a place to have a kid no it's
not
and um
of course that's you know I got
I got drop jobs you know after I had her
because I was like I didn't want to go
honestly I want to go but then
let's say what project people came over
and like you gotta just go like no I'm
not in girl because I lose my baby but
I'm glad I went because I would have
lost myself
and the baby probably for the baby she's
healthy she weighs six pounds 14 ounces
19 inches long
beautiful healthy little girl
but yeah I had it all natural my
epidural and she's by far the easiest
birth ever like
I have a son too and he's just turned 10
on 23rd
and uh after I had my son I was like
hell no I'm not gonna have another kid
but I did I got pregnant again after
that
and the guy was just at the time
we were using at a time too pretty heavy
and he was my boyfriend that turned into
a pimp and he was very abusive
I know he would hit me in the belly and
he would try to get me to get an
abortion and I fought it I didn't want
to do it I don't know
it's not his kid
it was good this one I've had I've had a
total of if I had all my pregnancies
live I have five kids today I was all
right yeah
so what happened to that child
the second one
I got pregnant with my boyfriend he's a
he's black and he turned into a pimp on
me but he wasn't a boyfriend first
I don't know where he is today or if
he's alive and I don't care I haven't
heard him in three years
and I really have no like I did them for
12 years and I have no idea
I don't even give a [__] I don't wonder
where he's at
I don't even talk to my best friend who
uh communicates with him anymore because
she communication and I was like I have
to you know
they have a um a company because I knew
I was having
and that he proud of me he pried me into
the last stage where it's legal to do
abortions in Utah
to the last day and I was gonna have a
little boy
still to this day I feel guilt
same
I took a life of a child like
kills me eats at me
but what can I do
and um
sad to say is I got pregnant again by
him
well another reason I have an abortion
because he wasn't sure if it's here too
because I was working as well and that's
another reason why he abused me and hit
me because he's like he's not in my kid
you know
but
so the next time I got pregnant he told
me an abortion I thought right okay I'm
not going to argue with you because I
don't have enough time you know you
gotta do it sooner than wait until you
know I already know you know so it seems
like I know I'm into the abortion and
then at that time I haven't got all the
implant where you can't get pregnant for
as long as you have in your arm and had
it in there for five years
so I had the impact in the arm for
whatever five years so I couldn't get
pregnant
it worked it's nice to know how to go
through the monthly cycle
but then I when I took the implant out
but the year before I got pregnant with
my daughter I have now
a year later
as I said I just pray to God for a gift
here she is
and they named her Miguel so
I'm sorry
and they gave her the name of the kill
because of the meaning to name akel
means gift from God
and that's what she literally is to me
she literally actually a gift from God
like she's Heaven Sent
so is your hope now to get her back oh
my belief in my hope I'm getting her
back yes
yes there's no doubt about that
so you were raised under the LDS yeah in
in Utah good is that something you're
going to go back to
well yes honestly I feel like I have
better hope there I probably get you
know
because my sister like this place now
there are good principles I'll give them
that you know
and there's no influences there's no
honesty
I feel like I'll be healthier at my
Darby healthier and this away from this
La has not been my cup of tea you went
from one extreme to the other huh you
went from one extreme to the other I
know and I feel it too and I feel I feel
amazing
I'm actually working on getting my
teeth replaced too
I've already gotten a 15 tooth pulled
and they're going to be doing the
impression to be able to put I mean a
partials for now until I get my feet
more because uh
makeup and the insurance Medicaid will
cover for the Dentures but not in
patents unless your teeth are gone yeah
I'm missing uh yeah
that's what drugs will do oh yeah I'm on
the path to get my face back together
and my life out together and my baby
back in my arms and that's what I'll do
and I'll get stuff until I get there and
uh yeah
so my sister
is actually working right now trying to
uh
become a foster parent
so that she can be able to
work with the state here and be able to
have them do the reassessment
walkthrough at my sister's house
and okay you know I'm seeing the paper
with them it's like hope I'm hoping
that come to fit you know everything's
done and cleared that they'll say okay
the mom's been doing a great program
she's
healthy she's out everything you've ever
done is gonna clean
past four months two months ago I was
hoping and praying to God that there was
my baby go be with my sister and then
let me go save kids up my sister has
questioned me at her house
my assistant was a family she's actually
um
this outside she's not really in the
combine I do believe you know that the
courts will rule my papers and I'll help
I guess let's see they let me go back
home and get into a program outpatient
rehab down there because I finished four
months in patient at the Tarzana
Treatment Center
and then right now I'm in uh
[Music]
recovery Bridge housing is there in the
valley
and I'm getting two months there unless
I can get them of course to let me go to
Utah and that's why right now I'm having
my sister looking around for outpatient
program so that we can find her and we
can say to the judge hey we found an
outpatient program here in Utah she can
get started the day she comes I'm hoping
like with that they'll let me you know
say okay
but then again I was thinking about it
and thinking about us until yesterday my
tears and I'm working on a teacher now
here and that's going to be a process
until about September my birthday is
September 13th
so I'm thinking that I might just wait
until the court date before I call my
dentist because it happened Impressions
yet
so I went to the court date and see
what's going on there and then
oh there's been a smart ticket from Utah
or I'll call the dentist here at the
Fried Chicken Fisher in the valley and
then a couple of The Impressions and get
getting started on him again now
physically you look healthier
I feel amazing yeah like my anxiety I
mean I used to Shake It Up
I don't know if you remember that
or I rock back and forth but I had bad
anxiety like
I came so far like
I can talk easy enough like before it's
like it's hard for me to talk so in the
rehab you got clean from was it cracked
yeah not not fentanyl or Crystal map no
I've um crystal meth when I started
crack cocaine I quit the crystal meth so
these drugs seem to like replace the
other yeah so you you went from crystal
meth and addiction
heroin then I went to Utah for the
remember I went to Utah for the family
reunion
and I quit um heroin when I was there
and for someone like everything out
there for two weeks then I came back
here and I came back here I started
doing Crystal again but then I started
getting into this crack again you know
somebody asked me to crack a crack could
always be my choice to drugs and yeah
that somebody offered it to me and um I
think I was smoking that and I stopped
slamming I stopped slamming because the
mouth and I smell crap how did you get
clean from crack
I um had my beautiful daughter
no but I mean physically you just went
cold turkey and that was it yeah
because I was like I wasn't using the
whole time I'm playing with you I'll be
honest here but by the time I go out to
do return Shake I would get loaded yes
you know because I'm on the streets and
like so
yeah so I'm gonna have my daughter and
that's that I had my daughter was the
main goal I mean putting like
seeing her like I didn't want a daughter
I was mad I I wanted the Sun but I have
a son but when I when I had her that was
a whole changing Point like she's
beautiful I'm gonna keep her and I lost
her
maybe they go to the hospital after I
had her
and they questioned me
and I denied a detox test because I knew
that I'd be instant taken away from babe
my baby took money instantly
naked person to me I had it for four
days they kept me there for four days
because I had a fever up to 102. that's
why I say it's a good thing I didn't go
in because I had an infection and I
didn't know if the placenta came all the
way out
but it did you know
so Virginia what have you learned about
life and everything from I learned
there's so much in life there really is
and I realized how
it's sad like every back of my life and
how much you know
because then there's so much I want to
do there's so much I'm going to do like
my goal is to
start my business
I want to start my own business it's
gonna be a doggy fashion you know my dog
seems to be a little model you know
modeling because I mean take pictures of
her within I mean I know how to sell
I've been selling since I was eight
years old
so my goal is to start my own business
and I wish I were you know there's no
drug that could have because I had
things some time ago
but
and like I see my friends out here and I
can't like it's sad to say
I can't really call them friends
but I was on an Associates
and I don't use anymore so
my two friends I have are the ones I'm
in sober living
and all I can say is I'm
just so much to live for and I just I
wish there's somebody I could like
get onto people's head before it's too
late I
I had a friend that was pregnant and
pronouncing time I was and I don't know
I don't know what happened to her I see
her baby on Facebook but I don't know if
she crossed custody or not
because she was smoking up up to you
know too like
well you know I suppose there's a way
that I can help people help them see
that someone slip word it's just life is
beautiful there's it really is
like I see myself going going far to
come you know
I don't want no boyfriend I don't need
no boyfriend I got a baby
I got my dog I got my son Utah
yeah I probably had one more kid but
even then I don't want to die in my life
I just want my babies I can be Dad and
Mom
Virginia thank you so much for coming
back and showing us in what's going on
going to Utah and my life
my parents still take an RV which I'm
going to do and travel the world and I'm
going to stay in each state six months
to a year and starting my business you
know or everybody I cannot do a
I want to do my business because I
cannot see myself doing a nine-to-five
job because I don't trust babysitters
due to I lost my son by trusting the
wrong babysitter
so
that's my goal is to
stay clean no matter what I don't have
that thought
even at all even being out here it's not
tripping for me I was like you know
I just can't wait to get out of here
that's when I see my baby my dog you
know because I come here
early in the morning spend over time but
tomorrow it seems different because I'm
going to start the outpatient
you gotta Pat myself on the back and
then proud of myself yeah I'm proud of
you thank you all right thank you very
much